RECORD.
LISA?
>> Lisa: THANK YOU, CATHERINE.
JOINING ME NOW, COREY
LEWANDOWSKI, TRUMP'S 2016
CAMPAIGN MANAGER AND COAUTHOR OF
THE NEW BOOK, "TRUMP I'M A" OUT
NEXT TUESDAY.
AND FORMER SENIOR ADVISOR TO THE
HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND THE
CEO OF BLUE OF BLUEPRINT
STRATEGY.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING WITH ME
TONIGHT.
>> HELLO, LISA.
>> Lisa: I WANT TO START WITH
YOU, ANTOINE.
IF THERE IS POTENTIALLY NEW
INFORMATION, IT IS THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE'S JOB TO INVESTIGATE.
WHY WOULDN'T THEY LOOK INTO
THOSE?
LISA, THIS IS A PRIME EXAMPLE
WHY THE REPUBLICANS LOST CONTROL
OF THE CONGRESS, JUST A FEW
WEEKS AGO.
THEY HAVE INVESTIGATED
THEMSELVES INTO THE MINORITY.
HERE WE ARE ONCE AGAIN WASTING
TAXPAYERS DOLLARS ON SOMETHING
THAT DOES NOT EXIST.
THEY SPENT SO MUCH TIME FOCUSING
ON HILLARY CLINTON THAT THEY
HAVE NOT SPENT TIME PUTTING
FORTH A POLICY AGENDA THAT WOULD
MOVE THIS COUNTRY FORWARD AND
THE VOTERS RESPONDED THE WAY
THEY DID ON TUESDAY NIGHT.
>> Lisa: CORY, WHAT DO YOU
MAKE IT WOULD ANTOINE DROZD
SAID?
>> IT'S THE TRUTH!
>> IS IN AT THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE'S JOB TO CONDUCT
OVERSIGHT?
>> OF COURSE, LAURA.
IF NEW INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE,
MARK MEADOWS AND HIS COMMITTEE
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO THE
AMERICAN TAXPAYERS AND POSITIVE
YOU TO DO THEIR JOB, TO
INVESTIGATE WHATEVER THAT MAY
LEAD.
WE ALL KNOW THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION WAS NOT ON THE UP AND
UP.
MY ONLY DISAPPOINTMENT WAS OF
THE CONGRESS HAS TAKEN THIS LONG
TO CONTINUE THE INVESTIGATION,
THAT IT WASN'T DONE FOR THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT PRIOR TO NOW.
THERE IS NO WAY THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS OR THOSE COUNTRIES
WHO
FROM OVERSEAS THAT GAVE TENS OF
MILLION DOLLARS TO ACCESS TO THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION, WHETHER AS
SECRETARY OF STATE OR AFTER,
DOING SO OUT OF THEIR GOOD WELL.
WHAT YOU HAVE SEEN NOW, THE
GROWTH OF FOUNDATION IS NOT
RECEIVING THOSE TYPES OF
DONATIONS ANYMORE.
CLEARLY, IT WAS A PAY TO PLAY
SCAM AND NOW THERE SHOULD BE A
MUCH LARGER INVESTIGATION TO
BRING IT TO LIGHT BECAUSE THE
CLINTONS HAVE ALWAYS OPERATED,
IT'S ONE SET OF RULES FOR THEM,
THEM, --
>> Lisa: I WANT TO ASK YOU
THAT.
I WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON WHAT'S
BHO SAID.
IF WE HAVE SEEN A DROP OFF ON
DONATIONS, IF DONATIONS WEREN'T
MEANT TO GIVE ACCESS TO
HILLARY CLINTON, WHY THE DROP
OFF?
>> MAYBE PEOPLE HAVE MOVED ON,
AND MAYBE THE CLINTONS HAVE
MOVED ON.
COREY JUST SWALLOW THE BIGGEST
BULL OF HYPOCRISY EVER SEEN.
HERE WE HAVE THE REPUBLICAN
MAJORITY IN THE PRESIDENT TRYING
TO STRIKE FEAR IN THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ABOUT INVESTIGATIONS,
AFTER INVESTIGATIONS, IF THE
DEMOCRATIC OVER THE CONGRESS,
AND NOW YOU ARE SITTING HERE
TONIGHT, COREY.
IT'S OKAY, CONGRESS HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO INVESTIGATE.
WHICH WHEN I SAID?
YOU CAN'T HAVE YOUR CAKE AND EAT
IT, TOO, MY FRIEND.
THIS IS THE LAST STRAW BY THE
REPUBLICANS TO DRIVE A WEDGE
INTO THE REAL ISSUES IN THIS
COUNTRY AND SEPARATE DEMOCRATS
FROM REPUBLICANS AND THAT IS
WHERE THIS IS ALL ABOUT.
>> Lisa: ANTJUAN, I'M PRETTY
SURE --
>> CONGRESS HAS AN OBLIGATION TO
INVESTIGATE AND THEY SHOULD
INVESTIGATE CLINTON AND
JAMES COMEY AND ANDREW
McCABE --
>> Lisa: HOLD ON, ANTJUAN.
>> LET'S GO INTO THE EMAILS!
>> Lisa: ANTJUAN, HOLD ON!
>> IVANKA TRUMP DID NOT BLEACH
BUT 33,000 EMAILS ON A PRIVATE
SERVER OR HAVE CLASSIFIED
EMAILS ON HER OWN SERVER AND
SAY, WHOOPS, I DIDN'T KNOW THAT
AS A SECRETARY OF STATE OR
FORMER U.S. SENATOR THAT I CAN
TO SCORE CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
ON MY PRIVATE SERVER.
SHE NEVER DID THAT.
LET'S INVESTIGATE
HILLARY CLINTON FOR PUTTING ON
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION ONTO HUMA
ABEDIN'S SERVER, OF WHICH HER
EX-HUSBAND HAD ACCESS TO, THE
FBI KNEW ABOUT IT, AND DID NOT
PROSECUTE ANY OF THEM, BUT
ACTUALLY GAVE THEM LENIENCY
BECAUSE THEY CLAIMED THEY HAD
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE,
CHERYL MILES, HUMA ABEDIN, AND
HILLARY CLINTON.
>> Lisa: ANTJUAN, BECAUSE NONE
OF THIS CONCERN YOU?
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE KNOW
THAT THE DOJ'S LOOKING INTO,
POTENTIAL PAY TO PLAY.
"THE ASSOCIATED PRESS" RECORDED
ABOUT CLINTON DONORS GETTING
ACCESS TO HILLARY CLINTON'S WITH
MEETINGS.
YOU KNOW, A PRINCE WENT TO    TH
YOU KNOW, A PRINCE WENT TO    TE
CLINTON FOUNDATION TO TRY TO GET
ACCESS TO HILLARY CLINTON.
WHEN HE COULDN'T GET TO HER VIA
THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
YOU LOOK AT THINGS LIKE THE
INTERNATIONAL BUSINESS TIMES
REPORTING THAT ARMS SALES
INCREASED TO GOING TO FOUNDATION
DONORS.
HOW DOES NONE OF THIS CONCERN
YOU?
>> LISA, WHAT DO YOU AND COREY
AND I BOTH KNOW, ALL THREE OF US
NOW, IS THAT IF THERE WAS A
WRONGDOING BY THE CLINTONS, IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN HEADLINED, FRONT
AND CENTER, ALL THE WAY THROUGH
EVERY NEWS OUTLET --
>> Lisa: FOR THE DOJ IS
LOOKING INTO IT.
>> THE INVESTIGATION WOULD HAVE
BEEN THE TOP FRONT AND CENTER OF
HIS NETWORK AND EVERY OTHER
RIGHT-WING NETWORK YOU CAN
IMAGINE.
YOU AND I BOTH KNOW THAT.
THERE IS NO THERE THERE.
I THINK WE ARE GOING TO FIND
THIS OUT.
THIS IS THE LAST STRAW BY THE
REPUBLICANS WILL MAKE THEIR WAY
THROUGH THE MAJORITY AND THEY
TRY TO RAISE AN ISSUE WHERE
THERE IS NO ISSUE.
>> Lisa: COREY, WE DON'T KNOW
THAT HE HAD, DO WE?
THE DOJ IS LOOKING INTO THIS.
WE --
>> THEY WOULD HAVE SETTLED IT BY
NOW.
>> Lisa: THEY ARE LOOKING INTO
IT, ANTJUAN.
COREY?
>> WE DON'T KNOW AT THE BOTTOM
LINE IS BUT WE DO KNOW THAT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL IS STILL
LOOKING AT THE CROOKED MEMBERS
OF THE FBI, WHETHER THAT IS
JAMES COMEY OR McCABE --
>> HERE WE GO.
[LAUGHS]
>> THAT'S A FACT.
THE IG IS LOOKING INTO THOSE
PEOPLE.
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE FBI
HAS BEEN REFERRED TO A CRIMINAL
REFERRAL FOR LYING UNDER OATH ON
THREE SEPARATE OCCASIONS.
WE KNOW THERE IS A PART OF THE
CLINTON TEAM, BRUCE OHR AND
NELLIE OHR, PART OF FUSION GPS,
ALL TIED TO THE CLINTON CABAL,
AND WE ARE GOING TO FIND OUT
ONCE AND FOR ALL WHAT THEY DID
TO TRY TO SUBVERT THE WILL OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND IF THEY
WERE INVOLVED IN ANY WAY, SHAPE,
OR FORM, FALSIFYING A FISA
APPLICATION JUST BY AMERICAN
CITIZENS BECAUSE OF IF
DONALD TRUMP WASN'T ELECTED, WE
WOULD NOT KNOW ANY OF THOSE
THINGS.
>> COREY, BLESS YOUR HEART.
YOU'VE DONE A GOOD JOB OF
REPEATING --
>> Lisa: ANTJUAN, --
>> YOU'VE DONE A GOOD JOB OF
REPEATING TALKING POINTS BUT YOU
KNOW AND I KNOW THAT IS A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF REALITY.
THAT IS FICTION, NOT FACT.